ein mann erschoss gestern abend in hanau
insgesamt 9
es war wie so ein schuss ins herz bald
wird auch bestätigt dass es sich um ein
attentat mit rechtsextremistischem
hintergrund handeln könne
wir sind alle mit ihnen gestorben
ganz klar zu machen dass die opfer eben
keine fremden mann
[Musik]
wer heute also der status drehs in hanau
und ja ich habe keine ahnung was mich
erwarten dass man versucht sich ja auch
immer in die lebens und gefühls und
gedankenwelt von den protagonisten
hineinzuversetzen die man trifft aber
das geht natürlich nicht ich durch kein
neonazi einen angehörigen verloren habe
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ich wäre unehrlich also
ich war dabei und ich habe mich erst mal
gar nicht mehr getraut aus dem haus zu
gehen
so war das halt jeder fremde menschen
malweise ist mir hier niemand fremd
wir lieben uns alle hier wir alle also
ich konnte drei uhr nachts durch die
straßen laufen mit kopfhörern hatte
nichts und niemand angst vor allem an
ist auch hier geboten
[Musik]
eigentlich habe ich mich zu hause
ich wollte eigentlich so viel raus
wollen wir ins jugendzentrum juz war für
mich kesselstadt ist meine heimat ist
nicht mehr so ich glaube niemand in
kesselstadt oder haben hätte damit dem
einschnitt weil wir hier so vielfältig
zum untergrund und alle gut miteinander
leben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also erstmal aus journalistischer sicht
finde ich wichtig dass man mit anstand
und respekt an so einem ort kommt um mit
den menschen umgeht was wir immer tun
aber hier ist glaube ich schon noch mal
eine besondere atmosphäre und auch
situationen weil wie zum beispiel
garagen die war dabei so und freunde
verloren die kannte jeden der opfer und
da finde ich muss man auch noch fraglich
okay ist dass man auch in diesen doch
sehr intimbereich reingeht
[Musik]
danke das war wie so ein schuss ins herz
und alle waren oder sind noch also denn
er spürt es auch noch hier und das ist
ja er hat einfach viel kaputt gemacht in
kesselstadt oder hier im jugendzentrum
das hat einfach ganz viele leute
betroffen die also jeder kannte
irgendein das waren viele der opfer sind
hier aufgewachsen und waren nachbarn
geschwister viele haben sind auch in
diese bar gegangen und haben es einfach
überlebt so ein bisschen später gekommen
oder waren dabei und haben nicht
getroffen aldi die sind auch hier und es
war schon das war schon gut zusammen zu
sein
[Musik]
also jeder der mal sport gemacht hat vor
allen dingen in der gruppe weiß was das
für eine energie ist was für eine kraft
ist dass es um zusammenhalt geben und
ich glaube dass der ort diese
gemeinschaftliche zweitfamilie die jungs
und mädels hier gefunden haben auch halt
gegeben hat und zwar weil sie vorher
schon so eng beieinander waren
das finde ich ganz ganz toll so alles
menschen alle alle so wie sie sind kein
fake sondern total authentisch und es
hilft kann ich mir vorstellen
ich finde einfach wahnsinnig wichtig das
was uns alle gesagt haben
die erinnerungen müssen wachbleiben um
die zukunft zu verändern und es war
schon ein paar mal ganze hot water um
geholt
[Musik]
schön dass sie in hanau sind unschön
ja was ist ihr antrieb sich um die opfer
familien zu kümmern
ich fühle mich dazu verpflichtet das ist
wirklich seit dem 19 februar so dass ich
mich dazu verpflichtet fühlen
also ist kein auftrag so sagen kann also
ist auch das was ich mir selbst gegeben
habe gemeinsam mit den anderen
mitgliedern dabei hat das ist die
verpflichtung einfach diesen schmerz zu
teilen
vielleicht eine gewisse resozialisierung
der betroffenen menschen der angaben
mittelfristig betragen
das ist unsere verpflichtung was mir
aufgefallen ist dass in der stadt immer
wieder und an ganz vielen orten die
bilder noch hängen auch um sich zu
erinnern um nicht zu vergessen wie
wichtig ist das für sie auch hier an dem
tatort
also für mich und für die angehören mit
dem wir da ich ständig täglich im
austausch sind auch diesbezüglich es ist
sehr wichtig weil den ist sehr wichtig
dass den liebsten eben nicht vergessen
dass auch nicht so viel über den täter
unbedingt die öffentlichkeit gesprochen
wird sondern um die opfer um die tat wie
grausam dass eben dann auch gewesen ist
also hier ist der eingang zum haus
gewählt
und hier ist die arena und verstecken
sich hinter der theke ich weiß nicht
alle auf einen haufen geschmissen und
man muss sich zwischen sich so ein
bisschen chillen weil man kann sich
eigentlich war wie bei aktenzeichen xy
ungelöst und ich vielleicht braucht man
das auch um die distanzen zu bringen ich
da wenn man sich das wirklich bildlich
vorstellt was hier passiert ist man
kennt die bilder ja in teilen neben
teils ist es so unfassbar dass es schon
wieder total surreal ist und dann spielt
der kopf einem doch einen streich weil
natürlich die bilder einfach kommt der
kopf setzt die sachen eigentlich
zusammen und auf der anderen seite ist
genau das unser job da hinzugehen zu
zeigen darüber zu reden mit den
betroffenen zu reden und vieles vieles
mehr
das hat aber nicht geklappt weil wir
sozusagen unsere vereinskonzept ein
bisschen also wir wollen ganz raushalten
das ist zum beispiel ungewöhnlich und
selten dass wir so gut begleitet werden
von jedem haben der ja alles von a bis z
kendall dafür vielen dank wirklich dann
weil es so ein sensibles thema ist
[Musik]
ja
wichtig ist das für sie gemeinsam jetzt
hier zu sein und das auch gemeinsam zu
verändern was gemeinsames zu starten
sehr sehr wichtig weil wir alle haben
die selben schnell und bisher beziehen
und das ist das ziel
wir möchten eine lückenlose aufklärung
der tat
es ist keine sondern 900 familien
verwandschaften wir sind alle mit denen
gestorben
wir leben aber wie wir sind auch winde
leiche
[Musik]
diese form von alltagsrassismus die auch
zugenommen
das hat so genommen ich wurde letztes
jahr im dezember zum ersten mal in
meinem leben auf dem weg zum hannover
weihnachtsmarkt von einem mann also fast
sogar körperlich angegriffen ja ich sehe
mich in meinen land verbissen
kopftuchzwang ich heiße und das habe ich
zum ersten mal dermaßen erlebt dass ich
wirklich angst hatte und dass ich dieses
angst habe hat mich stark gestört weil
ich habe in diesem land eigentlich keine
angst
und dass ich das halt wirklich hatte und
alltagsrassismus ist realität geworden
in deutschland
[Musik]
ich bin in hanau geboren und mit zeit
lang war ich in london habe dort
studiert dann kam ich wieder nach hanau
nach fünf jahre london auf nach kam ich
nach hanau weil ich mich so verbunden
fühlt mit meinem heimatstadt dass ich
mir gedacht habe obwohl london so
multikulti ist auch dort ein traumjob
hat habe ich gesagt nein ich will wieder
zurück nach hanau und ich habe in hanau
so viel rassismus dann erlebt aber
nachdem es wirklich salonfähig wurde
nach dem rassismus salonfähig wurde und
in die mitte der gesellschaft angekommen
ist
davor war dass ich so die letzten zwei
jahre ist es extrem geworden aber vor
allen dingen auch noch mal ganz klar zu
machen dass die opfer eben keine fremden
bahn sondern menschen wie du und ich
mit oder ohne migrationsgeschichte teil
dieser gesellschaft teil dieser starb
[Musik]